la cour d'appel a décidé de ne pas le
renvoyer en prison est à quelle heure ça
a quelle heure ça c'était à 9h 9h30 ce
matin c'était le jugement
suite au référé du du procureur de Melun
la couche que vous aimez bien les
horaires
mais là j'en ai pas beaucoup à vous
donner là c'est dommage à chaque fois
Pierre Palma est libre mais enfermé si
je comprends bien oui alors c'est quand
même la fin d'un bras de fer entre une
juge d'instruction et le procureur de la
République a gagné et ben c'est la juge
en section mais c'est le bon sens qui a
gagné finalement près de chez nous on a
on a offert un spectacle quand même un
petit peu
j'allais dire pitoyable le mot est
peut-être un peu fort mais un drôle de
spectacle aux justiciable
depuis le 10 février alors qu'il n'a
jamais mis un orteil en prison il a il y
a eu quatre décisions
dans ce sens enfin
c'est c'est alors c'est un dossier un
peu exceptionnel je l'entends mais
c'est la première fois que c'est
exceptionnel aussi ce genre de choses
alors là on en a connaissance si vous
voulez mais j'imagine que les procureurs
sont pas toujours d'accord avec les
juges instruction
et cette affaire est tout à fait
exceptionnelle mais là on a eu un
spectacle quand même un petit peu un
petit peu de curieux
il était il était blessé il a été
hospitalisé dans un premier temps tout
de suite après l'accident
on doit le statuer si on s'en sort
juridique c'est à dire que la juge
d'instruction doit qualifier les faits
qu'on lui reproche ça c'est le premier
la première étape judiciaire ensuite on
doit statuer sur l'endroit où on va le
mettre c'est à dire privation de liberté
on le laisse en liberté ce qu'on met un
contrôle judiciaire etc là il a été
décidé à ce moment-là qu'il fallait le
soigner je pense que c'est d'ailleurs
une bonne une bonne décision il va donc
dans un service addictologie se faire
soigner pour ces pour ses problèmes
d'addiction le parquet de Melun le
procureur de Melun n'accepte pas cette
décision fait donc appel de cette
décision et c'est la chambre de
l'instruction qui pour une première fois
va devoir
statuer entre le juge et le parquet
la chambre de l'instruction a donné
raison au parquet
sur de lui
rentrez pas dedans
le parquet a obtenu Yanko enfin on a
accédé à sa demande donc on décide d'un
carcérer Pierre Palmade qui reste à
l'hôpital puisque toute façon il est
malade et en cours de route il s'est un
AVC
ce qui fait que est-ce qu'on a des
nouvelles de son état de santé là
j'ai quelques infos il paraît qu'il va
pas très bien
et si il est parti en Suisse
sont plus importantes on met tout ça au
conditionnel je vous dis mais au
conditionnel d'une petite info qu'on a
c'est les séquelles sont plus
importantes que ce qu'on pensait oui et
la décision est normale d'accord il
s'est rajouté à ça un problème a priori
cardiaque puisqu'il a été à Marie
Lannelongue qui est au Plessis-Robinson
qui est un hôpital spécialisé pour les
problèmes pour les problèmes cardiaques
et c'est dans ce contexte qu'on conteste
la décision du juge d'instruction de le
remettre en liberté c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas gérable d'avoir un type détenu
dans un hôpital qui a fait un AVC qui a
probablement un problème cardiaque c'est
incompréhensible et du coup la juge
d'instruction infinie a reçu un comment
s'appelle un certificat médical
concernant Pierre Palmade ou il est
stipulé que son état est incompatible
avec la détention donc à quoi ça sert
d'avoir d'un carcérer quelqu'un qu'on ne
peut pas incarcéré finalement il y a un
moment où il faut quand même essayer de
d'être logique si vous voulez et je
trouve que la juge d'instruction a été
logique dans cette histoire et la
décision de la chambre de l'instruction
lui a donné raison et fin de l'histoire
si vous voulez le problème c'est que
maintenant on ne peut plus le Nil
réincarcéré avant le jugement et on ne
peut plus non plus lui mettre une
surveillance électronique c'est un
bracelet électronique donc là il est
libre il est libre sauf que on lui
impose de rester à l'hôpital il est
libre à l'hôpital
pour recevoir des visites il a pas de
bracelet pour recevoir des visites
il est sous contrôle judiciaire le
problème si vous voulez qu'il va se
poser à mon avis dans pas longtemps
enfin je laisse faire pour lui en tout
cas c'est quand ça sentait va
s'améliorer et que les médecins diront
que finalement il a plus rien à faire à
l'hôpital ça peut être donc un jour dans
un mois j'en sais rien il va falloir
resituer sur sa situation et là la juge
d'instruction va être obligée de
modifier le contrôle judiciaire
puisqu'elle ne peut plus lui mettre de
brasse électronique sauf à ce qu'il
viole son contrôle judiciaire oui je
voudrais vous donner des nouvelles d'une
des victimes parce que les informations
contradictoires qui ont circulé et là
j'ai fait un point avec l'avocat donc
Mourad bathique très bien ça concerne le
père le conducteur donc en fait il avait
été annoncé en fin de semaine dernière
qu'il était sorti de l'hôpital pas du
tout l'état de santé est très délicat il
est juste sorti du coma artificiel il
est toujours à l'hôpital il a eu cette
opération
le pied extrêmement touché je crois que
c'est la jambe gauche on ne sait pas
s'il remarchera il parle très peu il a
des problèmes de mémoire donc voilà son
état de santé c'est le seul des trop
hospitalisé puisque le jeune lui est
sorti en le 27 février le garçon de 6
ans et la la la dame qui a perdu son
bébé est sorti aussi mais le conducteur
voilà l'état de santé n'est pas bon du
tout merci pour ces infos dis-lui oui
vous qui connaissez vraiment bien la
justice très honnêtement est-ce que vous
ne croyez pas que en pleine retraite au
moment où la France est dans la rue on
n'a pas voulu faire de cet homme tout
d'un coup j'allais dire un exemple et
même un contrefeu sur les retraites et
surtout
voilà pour vraiment pour dire aux gens
pour assurer les gens je suis pas sûr
non pas sûr je pense que la justice est
quand même malgré tout indépendante là
vous avez eu un bras de fer enfin juge
et enfin une juge et un procureur le
procureur veut qu'il aille en prison la
juge probablement parce qu'elle a une
meilleure connaissance de la situation
se dit cet homme est malade on va le
soigner d'abord et on le jugera ensuite
ce qui une fois de plus me semble être
la bonne solution
je pense pas qu'il y ait de
d'interférence politique dans cette
histoire on a quand même du mal à
comprendre l'attitude du procureur qui
voulait vraiment le mettre en dépression
parce que la détention provisoire même
pour ce style dans Sous stupéfiant et
tout ça c'est pas la norme c'est ce que
les tout le monde nous réponds
pas ou non je crois pas il a voulu faire
un exemple j'en sais rien ça je suis pas
dans la peau du du procureur moi je vous
décrypte la situation
du mieux que je peux même si j'ai pas
les horaires
voilà
n'est pas dans la peau du procureur
d'interdiction aujourd'hui notamment
l'interdiction de conduire comment
est-ce que quand il va sortir on est sûr
qu'il va les respecter parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a un gap entre ce qui est
annoncé et la réalité il est tellement
connu son visage est tellement connu que
s'il prend une trottinette demain matin
il y a 15 coups de fil qui vont arriver
ou les rédactions ou aux commentaires
non Michel moi pardon j'ai discuté avec
un avocat pour le coup et qui m'a dit
que j'avais dit une bêtise à l'antenne
que j'avais dit qu'il faut qu'il aille
chez lui avec un bracelet tout ça il m'a
dit avant l'AVC avant l'AVC le risque
c'était qu'il aille chez lui avec un
bracelet qui est de la drogue chez lui
il prend la drogue il prend sa voiture
il faut savoir qu'entre le moment où tu
es tu prends ta voiture le bracelet
sonne et la police vient d'arrêter il
peut y avoir jusqu'à 30 à 45 minutes 45
minutes dans une bagnole c'était droguer
tu as le temps de faire un carnage la
police quand ça sonne elle est pas là
dans les trois minutes et il sonne pas
dès que tu vas et il sonne pas dès que
tu vas dans la salle de bain
c'était avant la vessie
mais statistiquement je pense que peu de
chance que ça arrive et une fois de plus
il est quand même tellement connu
physiquement que ou qu'il a il peut plus
aller nulle part en fait si c'est en
pleine nuit il peut sortir tout seul
pour résumer pour noter les spectateurs
qui nous rejoignent en prison
directement donc là il à l'hôpital mais
il est libre il peut recevoir des
visites et donc Pierre Palmade on attend
donc une fois qu'il sera plus souffrant
il va y avoir un nouveau jugement c'est
ça c'est les 25 qui ont la main pour
l'instant d'accord les médecins quand
ils considèreront qu'il est dans un état
de santé qui lui permet de vivre
ailleurs qu'à l'hôpital à ce moment-là
ils aviseront la juge d'instruction qui
prendra la décision d'un d'un nouveau
contrôle judiciaire
et les deux hommes qui étaient dans la
voiture non-assistance à personne en
danger ils font quoi ils se balade
moi je me dis si je fais la connerie et
qu'on est trois dans la voiture et qu'on
tape une voiture peut-être que je vais
tout de suite aller voir si je peux
sauver la mer le bébé le mec je me sens
pas en courant dans les champs sauf
qu'il a été constaté que la police avait
été prévenue quand ils sont partis
sécurité j'essaye de voir si tu as un
motard je touche pas ton casque les
trucs qu'on m'a appris quand j'étais
petit quand a quand tu es sur moi m'a
toujours dit non assistance à personne
en danger attention ça peut être grave
apparemment on peut se sauver très
méchant comme ça courir partir et là il
a il a interdiction de les fréquenter ça
veut dire qu'ils sont deux
en plus
ils sont libres statut de témoin assisté
pour le moment ils sont libres il n'y a
pas de charge à l'heure actuelle retenue
contre on verra lors de l'instruction et
pour le moment pas de chargement c'est
normal ça c'est normal parce que il a
été déterminé que peut-être ils ont su
spontanément sans savoir qui avait des
gens danger extrême etc donc moi
sinon devant moi excusez-moi c'est un
accident devant moi la voiture a fait
trois tonneaux et j'ai pas trop le temps
là je me barre on relève mes plaques on
va on me laisse tranquille on va pas
dire pour qui il y avait un mec qui
aurait pu sauver le bébé il est parti le
mec on me laisse tranquille ça existe
pas
ce que je pense c'est qu'on essaie de se
mettre à la place de gens qui ne
résonnent pas comme nous qui ne consomme
pas les mêmes produits que nous et c'est
impossible
ces deux garçons étaient depuis trois
jours sans dormir
ivre de drogue et je probablement
d'alcool je m'en fous mais j'entends
bien vous me posez la question de savoir
c'est la loi pour eux
ils vont être jugé ils
vont être moins priori a priori ils ont
quitté ils ont quitté les lieux après
l'arrivée des pompiers après voilà c'est
ce qu'on avait fait ça c'est l'info
qu'on a voilà une dernière question oui
la chambre de Pierre Palmade donc à
l'hôpital c'est une chambre normale tout
le monde peut venir il y a pas de police
il est libre il est libre il est libre
de ses mouvements mais il a pas le droit
de quitter l'hôpital voilà ça veut dire
que n'importe
quoi
aux gardes de l'hôpital mais il y a plus
de policiers il y a pas de gardien de
prison pour
pour ils ont allégé bien évidemment
c'est même dangereux
de circuler dans le local que les gens
j'avoue que pour les gens ça donne
vraiment le l'impression que ça
cafouille la justice quoi en France quoi
ça cafouille pour tout pour tous les cas
qu'on voit ici là on a rien compris il
sort il sort plus là un bracelet on lui
enlève il va en prison 4 jours après sa
gueule tous entre eux il est libre il
peut recevoir des visites des fleurs on
comprend rien escorté pour sortir pour
faire deux mecs de porter comme si
c'était le président de la République et
là il est libre de beaucoup de choses
et au bout de deux jours tu le vois au
relie à Chambon en train de lire mais
c'est n'importe quoi les mecs
tranquille on s'intéresse plus on
s'intéresse pas au train qui arrive à
l'heure la justice soutenait elle
fonctionne elle condamne elle fonctionne
à peu près bien et temps en temps il y a
il y a des ratés juste sur quelqu'un de
connu non c'est que je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de ratés mais on les voit pas
pareil je sais rien j'ai pas les
statistiques non mais on n'a pas les
statistiques des ratés les juges je
m'appelle pas bon me dire je me suis
planté
de Michel laisse tranquille Michel